is a person allowed to be in a state of
sexual impurity whilst they're
fasting as follow the question that can
a person be in a state of sexual
impurity that depends if as long as it
does not do any Haram act during the
fast for example it's mentioned in the
Hadith of wasallam in s Muslim volume
number two Hadith number 2453 it's
mentioned that um Salma may please with
her or the wife of the Prophet she says
that the prophet got up from his sleep
in a state of sexual defilement state of
sexual impurity while he was fasting and
he had a bath and he continued his
fast
further there's a similar message given
in s bukari volume number three in the
book of fasting Hadith number 1925 and
the Hadith is narrated Again by um Salma
may Allah pleas with her and
pleased with her too both are the wives
of the prophet and they said that the
prophet used to get up in the morning in
a state of sexual defilement because he
had intercourse with the wife not
because of a sexual
dream and he used to have a bath and he
never used to compensate the fast later
on this proves that being in the state
of junub sexual defilement or sexual
impurity does not nullify the fast
even if a person has a wed dream in
between his fast is valid the only point
to be noted is that the person should
have a bath as soon as possible if he
gets up in the morning after Dawn breaks
and if he's in a state of sexual
impurity should have a bath immediately
so that he can offer the Salah of f or
if he sleeps after F Salah and has a wet
dream and then become sexually impure so
he should have a bath at least before
the Z Salah so that he can offer the Z
Salah after having a gusul okay that I
think that shed some light on that issue
and the same thing if a person is
menstruating if a lady if she's
menstruating and she finishes the Minal
cycle just before
faj and she delays a bath even after
Dawn is broken and she has a bath just
before the F Salah that's also valid
excellent